hey every single year from now until the
rest of her life she will remember that
that's the day she found out that her
dad died how do you how do you get
justice for that little girl since this
happened I've talked to several people
who have said different things about
what went on about what mr. Brooke
should or should not have been doing
about what the officer should or should
not have been doing and to those people
I say with these new revelations again I
implore you look into your heart and
have some empathy for another human
being because that's what Rashard Brooks
is and was another human being he may
not look like you he may not be where
you're from where you're from but he is
another human being just like you Tamika
Miller is a human being she's a mother
she's a daughter she's a wife she's a
human being just like you so when you
see officer Rolf kick race are Brooks
after he shot him in the back while he's
laying on the ground dying think about
that before you start to get into things
that are that don't matter at all that
are completely irrelevant to this case
and and to generally just to all of us
as humans we should be together on this
not apart I was taught that you don't
kick a man when he's down I mean I
learned that playing sports I was taught
that that was a kind of an American
thing you know that is one of our ideals
we don't kick people when they're down
well what you saw and what we all saw is
one officer standing on a man who was
standing on top of him and then the
other officer literally kicking him
while he was on the ground dying
literally kicking him while he's down
what that showed me as I was watching
that press conference is this America is
not America for all Americans and as we
come to the July 4th holiday in a couple
of weeks there will be a lot of people
celebrating but there will be just as
many people who are not going to feel
comfortable celebrating who will still
be in the streets fighting for injustice
so again we ask everyone continue
fighting keep doing your part and stand
with and support this family because
right now they really need you thank you
I just want to say thank you and I just
hope that everything falls out how it
needs to fall out in these officers are
charged I'm really hurt Father's Day is
coming up and all I can do is just think
about what if my husband was still here
the biggest question is how does how do
we feel about the charges and there's a
lot of them a lot of charges this isn't
like a celebration or a victory lap of
watching these officers get charged
nobody's happy nobody's celebrating
because this never should have happened
we shouldn't have to celebrate as
african-americans when we get a piece of
justice like today we shouldn't have to
celebrate and parade when an officer is
held accountable for actions that we saw
in actions that we didn't know about
until today some people thought that we
would be happy and be celebrating and we
have a fist in the air but it's more of
disappointment that this is the state of
policing and this is where we're at but
I saw a lot of hope today
as the district attorney said this is
the first time another officer have
decided to be a government witness and
testify against another officer
that's what policing is that's the kind
of officers that make these streets safe
that stop instances like this from
happening when you're willing to step up
and say that was wrong even if that's
gonna risk my career even if people
won't like me and other officers will be
angry that's the reason that I always
say not every single officer is out
there trying to kill somebody but we're
also not going to play that rhetoric
game that y'all saw today of all
officers are great no we've seen what
has happened it's the same assumption
that we don't want officers making about
black people that all people are from
the ghetto that all people are hood that
all of us are up to no good
that you need to search every young
black male that you see which alert
which leads to situations like this it's
both assumptions so are we watching all
these policies that directly affect
families like this all these arguments
Democrats versus Republicans all of this
ridiculousness and they're not starting
from step one how do we actually fix
this and not what's best for your
political party because the things I saw
today we're gonna be back here next year
what's the point of national collection
of data if the data is flawed
we have handled cases where the Internal
Affairs reports aren't taken properly so
you'll be collecting data that is
nonsensical and doesn't hold officers
accountable unless you fix the
department internal affairs first but
they don't want reality they want
policies and elections and that's fine
but we'll end up here again so was this
justice today not yet we still don't
have a definition for it it was more
heartache that families have to go
through this and fight the public to try
and get justice for man they was shot in
the back twice but we do thank everybody
in this country for the outpouring of
support the people that are marching for
change peacefully keeping his name alive
positively and maybe one day this
country will get it right with policing
I will all come together brief questions
real quick the I didn't believe he will
plead guilty to anything
but the statements and information that
they've already gotten so far has led
them to believe that this is going to
help secure the prosecution of the other
officer for him to even come in and meet
with the district attorney as you know
that's rare and doesn't happen often so
we look forward to what he has to say
and how this will help with the
prosecution of the case
his presentation yes he was able to I
was very grateful I was very hurt being
there I would have done I would have
seen that for myself but I felt
everything that he felt just by hearing
what he went through and it hurt
you
you